la amenaza a la seguridad por parte de
corea del norte está evolucionando y
también debe hacerlo la alianza de
décadas entre eeuu y corea del sur los
líderes de ambos países dijeron que
habrá mayores simulacros militares y más
armas estadounidenses en la región
hoy el presidente john y yo nos
comprometimos a fortalecer nuestro
compromiso cercano y trabajar juntos
para enfrentar los desafíos de seguridad
regional
incluidas las amenazas abordadas
planteadas por el pueblo democrático de
corea al fortalecer aún más nuestra
postura disuasoria y trabajar hacia la
desnuclearización completa de la
península de corea promover la
estabilidad en el estrecho de taiwán y
fortalecer la libertad de navegación
incluido el mar de china meridional y
más allá de unidos a chang y envió el
mandatario estadounidense no descartó
reunirse con kim jong-un pero sólo bajo
la condición de que el líder norcoreano
sea sincero con respecto a retomar el
diálogo sobre el desarme en el segundo
día de su primer viaje oficial a asia
bardem dijo que estaba dispuesto a
desplegar activos estratégicos que
probablemente incluyen aviones de
combate y submarinos con misiles como
parte de la disuasión contra corea del
norte y para promover la estabilidad en
el estrecho de taiwán esta mayor
presencia militar seguramente molestará
a pyongyang pero también a su aliado
beijing que se ha quejado de la
intromisión de eeuu en la región el
recién elegido presidente de corea del
sur y en su guión dijo que la
estabilidad regional era una prioridad
absoluta tanto para la seguridad como
para la prosperidad y que se sumaría a
la nueva iniciativa comercial regional
de bailén hanyang un corea del sur y
estados unidos trabajarán juntos para
establecer un orden basado en normas de
la región del indo pacífico el primer
paso es participar en el marco económico
indo-pacífico
vayan viajará a japón este domingo un
día antes de asistir a la cumbre
nacional de quad que reúne a australia
india japón y eeuu